Alice you started the tournament slowly
but you picked up the pace just like a
very experienced player and you are a
very experienced player at such a young
age first of all congratulations from us
uh tell us a bit about today's game and
assess your overall performance in this
competition yeah thank you uh so for
this game I played like this 5 to
win the king Indian um it's something
that I prepared but I don't she
definitely like I haven't played I only
played like night Knight of three um and
I played it twice in this tournament so
I think out was the opening I was able
to get a pretty comfortable position I
mean uh I didn't get like the exact move
order but I kind of knew like the ideas
of the position uh till like around move
20 um so I think I I'm happy with the
opening position I got and then after
that I mean there was some point later
in the game where um so you knew the
ideas all the way to here yeah yeah yeah
I kind of knew like okay Bishop C2 um
Bishop D1 Bishop C2 Rook C1 I think I
probably should have done Queen D2
instead of Queen C2 earlier but um so
here like then I knew kind of the idea
that I'm supposed to go and try to
attack the A4 Pawn um and I was like
overall very happy with my position uh
here after this I thought that I would
probably be winning because okay but
Queen E1 I feel like I probably
shouldn't have done because um it I mean
I'm sure I'm still winning it's just
that it uh it's it's like it's not
unnecessary I could do something like
Queen E2 first then Bishop D2 and then
Queen E1 and uh it's pretty safe um or
Knight C3 and 94 okay but uh I think
after this I was still able to win and
it was uh very nice for me to win um
yeah so overall I started really badly
um in the first three rounds but I think
after that I was able to come back um I
think especially my round four win was
really important because that game I was
uh like it was super crazy I was winning
I was losing then I was winning again um
and for me to like get that like super
crazy win um I think is in some ways
even better than uh getting a solid win
um and yeah so overall I finished uh 7
and 1 half out of 11 and I think that's
uh a good performance for me um I broke
2400 for okay I did it before but this
is the first time where my official
rating should be above 2400 uh and
that's also something that I'm happy
about well congratulations and that in
fact will give you the international
Master title so uh that's quite
impressive Alice congratulations from us
guys any questions absolutely Alice you
are having incredible year again
congratulations on this performance you
also won the 2023 us junior girls
championships uh you played extremely
well winning gold medal on the first
board for the US national team at the
world Team Championships I mean the the
successes are just piling up what's next
for you what are your plans
um I think I have a few more tournaments
before uh the end of the year uh so
actually right after this I'm playing in
the I of men Grand Swiss tournament um
so I'll get a few days break and then uh
I'll be going to uh Iowa man tournament
um and that tournament is of course
pretty important um yeah so overall this
year has been pretty successful I was
not expecting this tournament to be uh
to end this way especially since I
started out so badly I was just hoping
to get an equal score um but yeah I'm
really happy with this result and also
some of my previous results um and I
hope at least in the next few
tournaments that I'm playing and I'll be
able to keep it up I don't want to put
any pressure on you but I'm being asked
by a lot of people uh if you are
aspiring to become grandmas you know if
you want to break that record before you
turn 15 I know you talked about setting
your own goals is Grandmaster Norm your
kind of upcoming
goal yeah um I mean I I will be playing
in some tournaments where I can't get
the norm after the next tournament if I
perform well enough but of course um
it's very hard I'll have to um keep
working on improving my a chess and um I
will of course try to become a
Grandmaster uh I'm not thinking about uh
any sorry record in specific um yeah my
microphone is it's okay take your time
commentators cursed Alice this is what
we deal with all the time no worries no
worries okay
but I know that awkward
feeling well we've had that yesterday
with fa trying to adjust his his
earpiece that was funny that was pretty
good stuff we're going to get that super
glue you know stick it stick them on uh
but we
we we're going to get Alice uh back
because uh she's for me fantastic let's
go back back Alice you're back welcome
back how
awkward
yeah Alice you were explaining uh
grandmas uh your goals and The
Grandmaster
title um yeah so I would like to become
a Grandmaster but I'm not I'm thinking
about like setting any records you know
it's uh it's a long process and I still
have to at least um improve my skill
because I don't think I'm at the skill
level quite yet but um we'll see I mean
of course it depends a bit on luck in
certain tournaments uh but uh hopefully
luck will continue to be on my side for
this year absolutely well you've had
again a fantastic year maybe not the
tournament that you hope for here but
very very good luck uh in the aisle of
man that will be well along with the
Qatar Masters which is going on now the
strongest Swiss tournament in the world
so uh definitely defitely a challenge
for
you yeah definitely thank you and there
are some uh candidate spots uh in I of
men as well so that definitely is a very
very important uh one do you have any
aspirations to qualify to the candidates
right
now um I mean okay I'll I'll try my best
um but I guess it's like it's extremely
hard the field there is extremely strong
so um I'll see I'll try to do my best
and I'll see where that takes me that's
going to be an interesting tournament to
follow for sure thank you Al thank you
very much uh just you know just Fant